Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine and today
I saw that Apple announced some new emojis now these will be out in a future release of iOS 11
They did give us a very small preview of some new ones on world emoji day
But today they gave us even more. so I kind of looked at them very quickly especially the animals
But I wanted to do sort of a reaction to them make sure you guys leave me some comments below and let me know what
your favorite old emoji is and also what your favorite new emoji is and the best part about this is you can comment with an
Emoji if you guys don't have an iOS device, that's okay
We can still see your emojis
And you can still see ours
so make sure you guys comment and let me know what your favorite is
The first one we have is a sign language for I love you which is awesome
I was also reading this has been a very highly requested emoji and guess what, here it is. next, we finally have the Giraffe
This is
Legendary and to go with the giraffe, the zebra
I recently went to Napa we did this really cool Safari where we saw giraffes and zebras
And I was trying to tweet about it, and I realized, "What?! There's no giraffe or zebra emoji
but guess what else there is a porcupine and a
dinosaur, a cricket, this isn't an
animal I think this is a dumpling or like a we call them pierogies does anybody know what a pierogi is pierogies are pretty famous
In Pittsburgh they even have at the Pirates games which is our baseball team
They have pierogi races or they have these people dressed up in costumes
And they chase each other around the field it's kind of silly. I'm not sure if they still do that
It's been a very long time since I've been to a Pirates game. Oh, we've got some delicious takeout food
This is interesting. This is a
piece of broccoli a little broccoli floret
preview of a future video
I wonder what type of pie this is supposed to be because this could really be any type of pie it could be an apple
Pie it could be a chicken pot pie
But let me tell you what it probably isn't it's probably not a pumpkin pie
and you know how I know this because I made a really big mistake and you guys will see this in a
Thanksgiving ish video I tried to make a pumpkin pie. Did you guys know the pumpkin pies
Don't normally have crust on top of them? You think that's something that is very common knowledge, but
It's something that I didn't realize. Next up we have this beautiful
very very luxurious. Blue hat. I wonder if they're gonna have the option to press down on it and
Choose different colored hats probably not, but if they did that's a pretty cool idea
Oh and look at this wonderful red scarf. I wonder if they'll do that same thing for this
I don't think they will I feel like this is probably a standard-issue color
But that would be really cool if they did that. Oops, I lost where I was, some winter gloves, a beautiful jacket
I actually like that jacket. It's very chic very
Detective like these next ones are pretty awesome
And a huge props to Apple for taking a stand and saying guess what we're gonna do this they have
Non-gender emojis, so these are amazing so here's one. Here's the next and here's the third I think it's pretty cool
Let me know what you guys think I next in addition to all the other heart emojis. They have a new orange heart
I'd say probably my favorite part out of all of them is the black one and the purple. Next we've got this a wonderful wizard
We have a not really sure what they're calling us
But it kind of looks like a little Tinkerbell. A vampire, which is perfect timing for Halloween and a mermaid
I feel like this is definitely long overdue. Here's a few of the new face emojis. We've got this one
I'm not really sure what's going on this little guy. He's just kind of like
This I definitely use all the time. It's the Shh emoji
I feel like there's so many times when well probably my sister will mostly use it on me. I'll just be yappin about something
It's gonna be the perfect time from one of the
Shh emojis this is also very interesting because it's one, two, three, four, five, five
character
swear word
And I'm going through the list of swear words that could possibly be and I feel like most of the really bad ones are four
letters
So it's kind of a good thing that it's five letters because more or less like you know we're not saying a bad bad word
We're just saying I'm not sure I would say comment below
with the swear word that you think it is but I do not want you to do that and I have swear words blocked
So you can't say them anyway in my comments.This one I like a lot. I love the little eyeglass guy
This is one of those things that I feel like me and my sister will use when we're not that we would ever do this
But if we were to say you know stalking somebody on the internet
creeping on their Instagram or on their Twitter
This is one of the perfect emojis for that and we never
Ever do that, and you guys probably don't do that ever like come on. This is a little sled
This is in kind of like the health and fitness wellness section
I guess I'm not really sure I mean I feel like this is one of those things like I don't mmm
I'm not really under percent sure I'm just rambling now. We can try to figure out what the sled is for
I mean is this like a dog sled is this like a fitness sled where you like put things on and then you push it
And pull it and get will fit. I'm something really sure with the saddest thing is that something else for fitness
Go like this
When you're doing lick push-ups or something? I will say. I probably will use this one more than once or twice
This is a beautiful spa emoji and the last one here on my list is a rock climber well
Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed this quick little iOS preview
I was so excited when I saw that they had new emojis coming out
Obviously we've been waiting for this for a really long time Apple has been teasing this for months
I mean, maybe even it's almost been a year at this point
I mean, there's so many emojis that it takes me longer to scroll through and find the one that I want
But what it's made it so much easier is in iOS
You can just type the emoji that you're looking for so for example giraffe
I can type that
What this is actually out the little giraffe mode you will pop-up below in the little predictive text you can click it
And then you don't have to scroll through all of them anyway. I will see you guys soon. I have a GoPro Hero
Comparison video coming out very soon, and I think I mention it on Twitter the image stabilization is amazing
I'll also have a week or I guess at this point. It's two weeks with iPhone 8 video
I've got some fun cooking videos for Halloween coming out and let's see I think there's something else too
But I don't remember at this point. I'll see you in the next one don't forget to subscribe if you're not already and
That's all I'm gonna go out of this video